What adding a few drops of pholvic minerals to my SCAC TB okay for me
I read that it can't enhance the absorption into the cells with the addition of pholvic minerals
So I don't know which pholvic minerals that you're talking about
So let me look up to your if I already talked if I already gave you the okay
That mineral then yes, you can if if you're like no, I just
Came up with this myself you didn't even look at the pholvic minerals for me
Then I need to look at them because there's minerals out there that are earth-bound minerals that are liquid minerals that I just very much against
And I actually created a couple blog posts on that
Why do I not like ionic minerals? I think it's the blog post
And I explained in that video
Why I don't like ionic minerals because they're not
They're not key-rated the way that we're supposed to eat minerals
So we get our minerals normally
from
plants
Yeah, so here's the blog post right here and
It looks like this so if you search for that why I don't like liquid ionic minerals you'll understand so
If you can send me Kelly if you can send me the the product I could look at it a little bit deeper